Saint-Pétersbourg,
la ville de tous les extrêmes.
Capitale impériale, fondée il y a
300 ans sur les rives de la mer Baltique
par Pierre le Grand,
elle est déchue sous l'ère soviétique.
Depuis peu,
elle renoue avec son glorieux passé.
Aujourd'hui comme hier,
la ville offre deux visages.
Aux hivers polaires
et leur nuit interminables,
succède presque sans transition des étés
parfois caniculaires aux jours sans fin,
un climat limité
à deux saisons très contrastées,
auxquels les habitants ont su s'adapter.
Depuis la chute du communisme,
de nombreux pétersbourgeois,
amoureux de leur ville, participent
avec passion à son nouveau rayonnement.
Nous avons passé un an auprès de Vladimir,
un architecte naval
qui se rêve en Pierre le Grand
et fait construire la réplique du premier
navire de la flotte russe, le Poltava.
Il nous faut
à tous une goutte de romantisme,
un sens de l'aventure,
avoir envie de faire renaître le passé.
Youri et sa brigade
de sauveteurs-plongeurs,
eux, protègent toute l'année
les pétersbourgeois des dangers de la Neva
et de la mer Baltique.
Notre boulot est difficile.
On travaille sous pression,
on est confronté
à des chocs psychologiques, à des risques.
Émotionnellement, c'est dur.
On doit affronter
n'importe quelle situation.
Marc, dessinateur français
installé depuis 11 ans, affronte,
lui, l'hiver
pour relever un défi insensé :
Sculpter les plus beaux joyaux
du musée de l'Ermitage sur glace.
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
il fait moins 9, moins 10.
C'est une température parfaite.
Entre passé et avenir, entre été et hiver,
c'est la double vie de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Le plus souvent,
le cœur historique de Saint-Pétersbourg
se découvre par ses canaux,
mais depuis quelque temps,
certains l'explorent un peu différemment.
Pour cela, il faut
savoir braver les interdits
et prendre de la hauteur.
-Bonjour.
-Salut.
Je suis Nastya.
Pacha. Je suis votre guide.
Quand on ira vers l'immeuble,
ne faites pas de bruit,
ni dans la cour, ni dans l'escalier.
Il ne faut pas
que les habitants vous remarquent.
Au programme aujourd'hui,
une balade à en avoir le vertige.
Nastya et ses amis font du roofing,
des visites clandestines
sur les toits de la ville.
C'est magnifique.
Une vue imprenable
sur la cathédrale Saint-Isaac,
la forteresse Pierre-et-Paul,
la cathédrale
Saint-Sauveur-sur-le-Sang-Versé,
le palais du prince Michael ou encore
l'incontournable musée de l'Ermitage.
Vu sous cet angle, c'est vraiment
la première fois que je vois la ville.
C'est magnifique.
Je n'avais encore
jamais vu la Neva comme ça.
J'ai envie de m'y baigner.
Riche de son architecture
et de son histoire impériale,
Saint-Pétersbourg est devenu
en quelques années,
la capitale du roofing en Russie.
Qu'est-ce qu'il fait ?
Pour Pacha le guide,
la seule vue ne suffit plus.
La tête dans la Neva
et les pieds dans les nuages,
le panorama prend
une tout autre dimension.
Moi, je suis sous le choc.
C'est une vue imprenable.
C'est génial de voir la ville comme ça.
En hiver, elle est
en noir et blanc, toute grise,
et là, elle a repris toutes ses couleurs.
À leurs pieds, sur la Neva,
une réplique d'un navire de guerre
du 18ème siècle
et la forteresse Pierre-et-Paul,
rappellent ce que doit encore aujourd'hui
la ville à Pierre le Grand, son fondateur.
On va s'asseoir où ? Sur ça ?
Ici, je perçois la ville
comme un tout, son esprit, son atmosphère.
Je comprends qu'on est entouré d'eau.
C'est ce qui rend cette ville si unique.
Quand Pierre le Grand a décidé
de construire cette ville ici,
on lui a dit : "Qu'est-ce que tu fais ?
Tu veux construire
une ville sur des marécages ?"
Il lui a répondu : "C'est très bien.
Je veux qu'on soit entouré par l'eau."
Pendant ce temps,
sur le fleuve Neva, Vladimir,
constructeur naval de Renault,
se rend à son bureau en bateau.
Ça, c'est la forteresse Pierre-et-Paul.
Pour la Russie,
c'est un lieu très important.
De nombreux événements
historiques s'y sont produits,
mais surtout,
c'est ici qu'est née Saint-Pétersbourg.
La forteresse a toujours été
importante dans ma vie,
parce que j'ai grandi
juste de l'autre côté,
dans le quartier de la pétrograd.
Notre maison était voisine
de la forteresse.
Au sommet, il y a un ange.
C'est l'ange protecteur
de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Il y a une dizaine d'années,
l'ange a été retiré pour être restauré
et tous les habitants ont eu peur
de se retrouver sans sa protection.
Il a fallu le remplacer au plus vite.
Attaché aux traditions,
Vladimir, dès qu'il en a l'occasion,
se déplace en bateau,
tout comme l'avait imposé
Pierre le Grand
aux riches familles de la ville.
Mes aïeux vivent à Saint-Pétersbourg
depuis des générations et des générations.
C'est ma ville,
je l'ai dans le sang, je l'aime.
Mes enfants et ma femme y sont nés.
En grand amoureux de sa ville,
l'architecte naval s'est mise en tête
de perpétuer l'œuvre de Pierre le Grand.
Avec André, son bras droit,
il nous emmène sur un chantier titanesque,
le projet de sa vie.
Ils viennent inspecter
les dernières avancées.
Va à gauche.
Je veux te montrer quelque chose.
Il ne devait pas y avoir
une coursive vers l'eau ?
Non, seulement vers le bas.
Ceci fait office d'échafaudage temporaire.
La soude définitive sera différente.
Il y a trois ans, Vladimir s'est mis
au défi de construire à l'identique
le premier navire de guerre dessiné
par Pierre le Grand lui-même, le Poltava.
Dis-moi, qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
depuis la dernière fois ?
On envoie le bout.
Il ne reste plus qu'à installer
la dernière [Inaudible 00:08:14-00:08:15]
et on aura fini cette partie.
À lui seul, le squelette du bateau
a nécessité 2000 chênes centenaires.
À terme, ce monstre des mers,
mesurera 43 mètres de long
et 40 mètres de haut.
Le Poltava a changé la position
de la Russie sur la Mer baltique.
C'est comme si on comparait
une puissance nucléaire
face à une puissance sans larmes.
Le Poltava a fait de la Russie
une superpuissance en son temps.
À l'époque,
Pierre le Grand employait 500 ouvriers.
Aujourd'hui,
Vladimir n'en emploie que 150,
mais tous sont habités
par ce défi hors du temps.
Comme dans un rêve
de petits garçons, fidèle à l'original,
le Poltava du 21ᵉ siècle,
aura aussi ses canons.
Je perce un trou
pour l'emplacement de la mèche du canon
pour qu'on puisse tirer.
C'est par là qu'on fera passer la mèche.
Le canon va tirer en vrai ?
Oui, pour de vrai.
Vous êtes un spécialiste en canon ?
Non, je suis tourneur, mais ça me plaît,
parce que c'est quand même l'histoire
qu'on transmet aux générations futures.
Qui d'autre que nous peut le faire ?
Allez, on prend la dernière tige.
Remontez de trois millimètres !
Maxime, 31 ans, est
le responsable de l'atelier des mas,
voilure et cordage.
C'est lui l'ouvrier le plus admiré
et le plus respecté du chantier.
Vous en êtes où dans les mas ?
Ça, c'est le troisième déjà.
Viens, je te montre
sur un plan où on en est.
Là, ce qui est en vert, c'est déjà fait.
C'est le grand Maxime Korchounov.
Il a été le capitaine du Shtandart.
Le Shtandart, c'était la première frégate
de la flotte russe sur la Mer baltique.
Il a été construit en 1703
sur le chantier naval de Ladoga.
C'est en Carélie.
Nous avons fait la réplique de ce navire
au début des années 1990
à Saint-Pétersbourg.
J'avais 10 ans
quand j'ai rejoint l'Équipe du Shtandart.
Au début, j'aidais à porter
les pièces détachées du navire,
ou je les comptais.
À 10 ans ? Comment c'est possible ?
Vous savez, en Russie, tout est possible.
Contrairement au Shtandart
qui navigue sur tous les océans du globe,
le Poltava lui restera à quai.
À son inauguration,
Saint-Pétersbourg pourra s'enorgueillir
du plus grand musée flottant du monde.
Avec ses dimensions hors normes,
le Poltava serait bien
en peine de naviguer sur la Neva.
Aujourd'hui avenue principale de la ville,
le trafic maritime est
intense et les dangers réels.
Dans la zone sud de la ville,
une brigade de sauveteurs-plongeurs
vient de recevoir un appel d'urgence.
Il y a un homme à l'eau,
je n'ai pas beaucoup d'information.
Apparemment,
il a été éjecté de son Jet-ski.
Il a besoin d'aide.
C'est tout ce qu'on sait.
Été comme hiver,
les sauveteurs de Saint-Pétersbourg
assurent une mission
de service public capitale :
plus de 6000 interventions par an.
Nous sommes au mois de juin,
mais la température de la Neva
ne dépasse pas 15 degrés.
Le blessé risque l'hypothermie.
Vas-y.
Il a mal au bras.
Le gauche ou le droit ?
Le gauche.
Comment tu t'appelles ?Sacha.
Qu'est-ce qui s'est passé Sacha ?
J'allais trop vite
sur mon Jet-ski et j'ai été éjecté.
Tu es mal où ?
J'ai mal au bras.
À part le bras, tu as mal ailleurs ?
Non, ça va.
Avec sa douleur au bras,
le blessé ne pouvait ni remonter
sur son Jet-ski,
ni atteindre seul la berge.
Il est prêt à être transporté.
Allez, on y va.
On va s'occuper de toi.
Tu vas aller à l'hôpital.
L'année dernière, été et hiver confondu,
les anges gardiens de la Neva ont sauvé
la vie de près de 450 personnes.
Malgré tout, 120 ont encore péri
dans les eaux froides de la ville.
Rentre tes jambes !
Impossible donc
pour les sauveteurs-plongeurs
de relâcher leur vigilance.
À leur tête, Youri, 34 ans,
ancien plongeur dans l'armée.
C'est lui qui dirige
les 400 hommes de la brigade.
Vous attendez le retour de Liternit,
ensuite, vous irez
patrouiller le long du quai.
Les ordres sont toujours les mêmes.
Attention, moi,
j'ai déjà dû intervenir auprès de jeunes.
Ce soir, Youri et ses hommes n'ont pas
le droit à l'erreur.
La ville accueille
le plus grand rassemblement de l'année :
la fête de tous les bacheliers de Russie.
Aujourd'hui, c'est le jour J,
le jour de la grande fête.
Pour certains, c'est du plaisir,
pour d'autres, du boulot.
Je vais voir mes hommes-grenouilles.
Ce sont les plus importants
de la soirée aujourd'hui.
Bonjour, enlève ta cagoule !
S'il se passe quelque chose,
un, le pilote démarre.
Deux, vous informez la centrale.
Trois, vous intervenez.
Vous êtes bien sur le canal 5 ?
Volodia, vous êtes bien sur le 5 ?
-Oui.
-Ok, on communique sur le 5.
En ce 21 juin, 800 000 personnes
venus des quatre coins du pays, attendent
avec impatience le clou de la soirée.
C'est le rêve
de chaque bachelier à Saint-Pétersbourg
d'assister à cette fête.
C'est unique.
On a notre BAC qu'une fois dans notre vie.
C'est comme cette fête.
Ça n'arrive qu'une fois dans la vie,
une seule fois.
À minuit, le ciel s'enflamme de 1000
feux pour accueillir les voiles rouges.
Un bateau mythique
qui symbolise l'avenir de la jeunesse
et le renouveau de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Des spectacles
comme celui des voiles écarlates,
ça n'existe nulle part
ailleurs dans le monde.
Saint-Pétersbourg est unique !
Merci à Saint-Pétersbourg
d'être une ville si incroyable
et bonne fête à tous les bacheliers.
Depuis que Poutine,
le pétersbourgeois le plus célèbre,
est devenu maître du Kremlin,
la ville renaît de ses cendres
et se rêve en phare de la nouvelle Russie.
Chaque année, Saint-Pétersbourg attire
toujours plus de touristes.
Pour découvrir le cœur
de l'ancienne capitale impériale,
ses 160 kilomètres de canaux
et ses dizaines de ponts,
le meilleur moyen reste encore le bateau.
Voilà l'endroit où aujourd'hui,
je vais dessiner le panorama.
Marc, lui, n'est pas un touriste.
Artiste français installé
à Saint-Pétersbourg depuis 11 ans,
il a le projet fou
de monter une exposition
de tableaux en glace.
En attendant des températures négatives,
il profite de l'été pour terminer
une autre œuvre tout aussi insensé.
Ça, c'est une maison
que je n'ai pas encore fini.
En trois ans, Marc a peint, un à un,
tous les édifices de la prospekt Nevski,
les champs Élysées de Saint-Pétersbourg.
Neuf kilomètres d'architecture concentrés
sur seulement
dix mètres de papier à mainlevée,
une œuvre unique
à laquelle il associe les passants.
C'est un projet, ce n'est pas long.
J'ai déjà dessiné 500 personnes
et j'aimerais bien vous dessiner.
C'est gratuit.
Ça prend juste cinq minutes.
Vous avez du temps ?
Le tableau, ça permet
de rencontrer les gens.
Parce que les Russes sont des fois
un petit peu timides de m'approcher.
Quand je le dessine, de suite,
il y a un contact et on peut parler.
Il y a une histoire.
Je leur demande
d'où ils viennent, pourquoi ils sont ici.
Ce qui me plaît,
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de création,
de créateurs, d'artistes, de musiciens.
Il y a toute cette énergie
que j'aime beaucoup.
À la fois, c'est une grande ville
et à la fois,
il y a des quartiers, des petites villes.
C'est comme un petit village
dans la grande ville.
J'aime beaucoup ça.
C'est un travail titanesque.
Vous pouvez m'aider ?
Regardez, je vais tout vous montrer.
Tenez-le
pour tout montrer à la petite fille.
Voilà.
Si Marc connaît toutes les façades
de la prospekt Nevski,
il connaît aussi les trésors
cachés loin des sentiers touristiques.
Pour arrondir
ses maigres revenus d'artistes,
il travaille aussi
à temps partiel comme agent immobilier.
Vous avez fait bon voyage ?
Merci, oui.
Attendez, je vais
vous prendre vos valises.
Ses clients cet après-midi,
une mère et son fils
tout juste arrivé de France.
Ça, c'est une très vieille maison.
Bonjour monsieur,
c'est la vieille sonnette d'autrefois.
-Bonjour, enchanté. Moi, c'est Alexandre.
-Bonjour, entrez.
Merci.
La spécialité de Marc :
dénicher des appartements
hors du commun
qu'il propose à la location au touriste.
Ici, c'est le grand corridor
qui dessert toutes les chambres,
avec le vieux linoléum
qui date de l'époque soviétique.
Il y avait sept familles qui vivaient là.
C'était un communal.
Il y avait un téléphone
pour tout le monde, vous voyez ?
Les gens pouvaient appeler indéfiniment.
Il y avait des tas
de dispute autour du téléphone
parce qu'ils bloquaient le téléphone.
Ce n'était pas payant, c'était gratuit.
Non, c'était gratuit à l'époque.
Voilà la chambre verte.
D'après moi, ici,
vous serez bien au calme,
mais en plus,
avec une super vue sur le canal.
Là, vous êtes au jour
le plus long, aux nuits blanches.
Comme il n'y a pas de volets...
Ils sont très beaux ces rideaux,
mais vous pouvez
les fermer, parce que la nuit,
vous allez être réveillés à 04h
du matin, en pleine nuit blanche.
Il n'y a pas de volet du tout ?
Non, il n'y a pas de volet.
N'hésitez pas.
Sinon, vous n'allez pas dormir.
On essaye de garder
l'ambiance un peu soviétique
et de toutes les époques d'ailleurs.
On essaie d'être en récit au maximum.
Il y a 15 ans, Dominique,
bijoutière de formation,
est venue s'installer à Saint-Pétersbourg.
Depuis, elle est devenue
plus Russe que les Russes,
tout comme son appartement.
On va continuer, si vous voulez.
Ici, c'est la salle de bain tout en bois.
On dirait presque un sauna.
C'est comme [inaudible 00:21:21-00:21:22].
C'est très chaleureux
pour prendre son bain.
C'est très bien.
La vue est un peu dur.
C'est typiquement Dostoïevski.
Montrez, whaou !
N'oubliez pas qu'on est
dans le quartier de Dostoïevski.
On est dans le quartier de Dostoïevski.
Ça fait un contraste entre le côté
canal et l'intérieur de la cour.
On n'est pas du tout
dans la même ambiance entre les deux.
Oui, les cours cachées, un peu sordides.
C'est sombre en tout cas.
C'est ça la Russie : les contrastes.
Voilà, c'est très bien.
Vodka maison.
À votre arrivée, à votre
beau séjour ici...
J'essaie de trouver
des appartements qui ont du charme,
qui... on va
se rappeler où l'art, la Russie,
Saint-Pétersbourg,
les couleurs sont présentes.
Au plus fort de l'été, à ces latitudes,
le soleil ne se couche pas avant minuit.
Ce sont les fameuses nuits blanches.
Ici le sénateur, je passe à bâbord.
Ce spectacle, touristes
et pétersbourgeois viennent l'observer
sur les quais et sur les bateaux-mouches.
Ils se prestent aussi
pour y admirer le travail d'un homme,
un homme que personne ne connaît,
pourtant, véritable maître de la ville.
Moi, je suis comme un policier
qui fait de la circulation à un carrefour.
Je régule
la circulation dans tous les sens.
Seulement, je suis à la manœuvre
d'une technologie ultra-puissante,
de mécanisme superpuissant,
d'une machine méga-puissante.
Depuis 34 ans, Serguei est aux manettes
du pont le plus emprunté de la ville,
le pont du palais.
1800 tonnes d'acier
et un million de boulons.
Il est 01h23.
Il ne nous reste plus que deux minutes.
C'est des entrailles du géant
que Serguei impose
ses règles aux noctambules
La sécurité, j'éteins la signalisation.
La circulation arrêtée,
plus moyen de passer d'une rive à l'autre.
Saint-Pétersbourg se retrouve
coupé en deux.
Attention, je lève les ailes du pont.
Voilà, c'est lancé.
Regardez le spectacle que je vous offre.
Chaque nuit,
les 13 ponts de la ville laissent circuler
les gros navires sur la Neva.
Saint-Pétersbourg devient
un carrefour maritime majeur.
Notre route fluviale
en Russie, a été pensée
pour qu'on ne puisse pas
éviter Saint-Pétersbourg.
Lorsque les navires arrivent
d'Europe et qu'ils se rendent
au centre de la Russie,
ils doivent obligatoirement
passer par Ici,
par la Neva, puis le lac de ladoga.
Ensuite, ils peuvent atteindre
le nord, le sud ou le centre de la Russie.
Le pont là-bas, c'est mon fils
cadet qui est aux commandes ce soir
et mon fils aîné travaille
sur le pont Toutchkov.
Toute ma famille lève les ponts,
moi, mes deux fils et ma femme.
À 02h30 du matin,
le jour pointe déjà à l'horizon.
Les amoureux des nuits blanches,
eux, profitent d'une dernière valse
avant la fin de l'été.
Sans avoir vraiment connu
d'automne, dès début novembre,
Saint-Pétersbourg doit
affronter un hiver polaire.
Les températures peuvent
descendre jusqu'à moins 30.
Emmitouflés, les habitants apprennent
dès leur plus jeune âge à résister
aux conditions climatiques extrêmes.
Pour Nastya,
le froid n'est pas un problème,
c'est même son élément.
Cette jeune femme de 24 ans,
est championne de nage en eau froide,
une pratique typiquement russe,
qu'elle va faire
découvrir aujourd'hui à ses amis.
Whaou ! L'eau a l'air super aujourd'hui.
En plus, il fait vraiment bon.
Il fait bon.
C'est ce qu'il nous faut.
Dans ce bassin creusé
au milieu d'un petit lac,
sportifs confirmés
et amateurs s'entraînent tout l'hiver
dans une eau à un degré.
Température extérieure,
ce jour-là, moins cinq degrés.
La spécialité de Nastya,
c'est le 50 mètres,
Cinquante mètres et pas un de plus.
Nager davantage pourrait
entraîner arrêt cardiaque et hypothermie.
Je viens nager tous les week-ends.
Pendant la semaine,
j'ai accumulé beaucoup de stress,
donc là, je m'en débarrasse.
C'est comme si je renaissais.
Ça me redonne des forces.
Je me sens en pleine forme
et prête à affronter la semaine qui vient.
Autour d'André de relever le challenge,
une première pour lui.
La vache !
C'est comme si
on m'avait retourné la tête,
comme si je revenais d'une autre planète.
C'était super !
Je reprends tout juste mes esprits.
Quand je suis sorti de l'eau,
je ne savais plus où j'étais.
Ça m'a regonflé à bloc.
Je ne pensais pas que j'en serais capable.
Vingt-cinq mètres d'un coup,
tu n'as pas eu peur ?
-Ça va ?
-Oui, super.
Tu vois comme l'hiver nous fait
du bien à tous les deux.
Dans la famille de Nastya,
tout le monde est nageur en eau froide.
Sa mère Olga, professeur de piano,
l'a initié dès l'âge de deux ans.
Les voilà les photos.
Elles sont vieilles et toutes décollées.
Voilà le moment.
D'abord, c'est moi qui me suis trempée
dans un trou creusé dans la glace.
J'avais l'air si heureuse
que mes enfants ont voulu faire pareil.
Mon fils avait onze ans,
ma fille, deux, et ils ont voulu essayer.
Après, ils se sont sentis
si bien, ils étaient tout joyeux,
surtout si fiers d'eux.
Pendant toute son enfance,
la petite Nastya se trempe
une fois par semaine dans l'eau glacée.
À l'adolescence, elle assiste
à une compétition de natation.
Une révélation !
C'était au bord
d'un lac entouré de montagne.
C'était vraiment beau.
L'eau était à quatre degrés.
J'ai voulu aller juste
m'y tremper, comme je fais d'habitude.
Tout d'un coup, je me suis dit :
" Pourquoi
est-ce que je ne nagerais pas ?"
Je l'ai fait,
toute une longueur, 25 mètres.
Tout de suite après, j'ai foncé m'inscrire
à la compétition à la dernière minute.
Depuis, ça fait six ans
que je participe à des compétitions.
De l'or en Estonie,
de l'argent en Slovénie,
elle enchaîne les victoires.
Cet esprit sportif est
très ancré chez Nastya.
Elle veut toujours
être la première partout.
Dans quelques jours, Nastya se rendra
au plus grand rassemblement
de baigneurs en eau froide de la ville.
Loin des quartiers populaires,
au pied de la cathédrale
Saint-Nicolas-des-Marins,
Marc, le dessinateur, prépare
son exposition de tableaux en glace.
Pour choisir l'étoile
qu'il va tenter de reproduire,
il se rend avec son fils
Danil au musée de l'Ermitage.
Profitez de la glace,
il n'y en a pas toujours de la neige.
Ce n'est pas à chaque jour.
Ancien palais des tsars et joyaux
de l'architecture Baroque russe,
l'Ermitage, c'est
le symbole de Saint-Pétersbourg,
mais également, avec ses 1000 salles,
l'un des plus grands musées du monde.
Regarde, tu la reconnais ?
-Bonjour.
-Bonjour madame.
Bonjour ! Ça va ?
Même s'il a déjà visité
à plusieurs reprises,
Marc a fait appel à une guide
pour ne pas se perdre dans le musée
et se noyer dans ces quelques
trois millions d'œuvres d'art.
Tous les murs, à droite et à gauche,
sont recouverts de petits portraits.
Ce sont des portraits des généraux russes.
Les petits formats,
ce sont des portraits de généraux.
Regarde un peu tout cet or, là.
Madame a dit qu'il y avait 20 kilos d'or.
Nous arrivons à une des œuvres
capitales de Matisse dans la collection,
qui s'appelle la ronde.
C'est celle-là qui est la plus célèbre.
C'est le nom que Matisse avait donné
lui-même à cette œuvre : la ronde.
Celui-là, Danil, il nous plaît.
Ça, tout le monde connaît.
L'Ermitage, c'est Matisse.
On ne va prendre celui-là.
Je choisis ce tableau, déjà par sa taille,
parce que nous, on a un grand tableau,
puis par les couleurs qui sont simples,
puis par ce rythme, ce mouvement.
Il y a trois couleurs, donc, je pense
qu'avec de la glace, on va y arriver.
Comme si reproduire des tableaux
en glace n'était pas déjà assez complexe,
Marc l'excentrique a décidé
de corser encore un peu plus le défi.
Tiens, regarde, tu sais ce qu'on fait ?
On pourra même trouver
un verre et le coller dans la glace.
Comme ça, on n'aura pas
besoin de s'amuser à faire le verre.
Rien que le verre,
la perspective est toute tordue.
Ça va être très dur
de trouver un verre comme ça.
Je voulais prendre
Picasso, parce que Picasso,
c'était mon voisin pendant 11 ans,
on habitait à 700 mètres l'un de l'autre.
Lui à Mougins, il est décédé en 1973.
Je me rappelle encore
de tous les drapeaux français
qui étaient devant sa propriété.
On allait même acheter
le pain à la même boulangerie.
Tous les autres tableaux de Picasso,
sont trop durs à faire en glace.
Celui-là, c'est
quand même un des plus simples.
Après Matisse et picasso,
Marc voudrait aussi rendre hommage
aux peintres russes.
Voilà, celui-là est super,
le tableau et les belles couleurs.
Regarde, le titre, parfait !
"Zima", Danil, l'hiver.
Celui-là, on va le prendre.
Je n'ai même pas
besoin de regarder les autres.
Marc est emballé
par un tableau de Kandinsky.
Je ne pouvais pas trouver mieux.
Je ne savais même pas
qu'il existait ce tableau.
C'est le tableau qu'il faut.
Il y a de la glace, il y a
de la neige, il y a des montagnes,
il y a le froid,
le bleu et toutes les couleurs.
Il est là.
Allez, on continue ?
Pendant ce temps, au pied de l'Ermitage,
Youri et son équipe font leur tournée
d'inspection quotidienne
sur le golfe de Finlande.
En hiver, sur la Mer gelée,
les risques de noyade
et d'accidents mortels sont
beaucoup plus nombreux qu'en été.
Tu fais genre, c'est ton territoire ici.
Oui.
Première victime : les pêcheurs sur place.
Allez, on est parti.
La première consigne,
c'est de ne pas aller sur la glace
si elle fait moins de sept,
dix centimètres d'épaisseur,
en particulier pour ceux
qui viennent en voiture sur la glace.
Puis, je leur explique
les premiers gestes de survie.
Vous pêchez quoi, les gars ?
Le gardon et voilà un sandre,
mais je l'ai pêché
un peu plus loin, celui-là.
La glace est épaisse ici ?
Elle atteint 30 centimètres ?
Non, 15 centimètres peut-être, voire 20.
15-20 centimètres, ce n'est pas mal.
Allez, on mesure la glace.
Il y a souvent des hommes
qui tombent à travers la glace
dans le golfe de Finlande, dans la Neva,
et là, l'expérience et l'excellence
de nos sauveteurs-plongeurs est
déterminante,
puisque chaque seconde est
vitale pour sauver un homme à l'eau.
On vient de mesurer la glace
sur la Neva, elle faisait 33 centimètres,
même avec le passage des brise-glace.
Ça fait même plus ici, 35.
Cette année, la glace est bonne.
Je vous donne ça.
Quand vous aurez une minute, lisez-le.
C'est important quand même.
Je le ferai circuler.
C'est bien de discuter
avec des gars comme vous,
parce que parfois,
on a affaire à des pêcheurs bourrés.
Là, il faut leur parler autrement.
Nous, on est sobres.
J'ai 74 ans.
Ça fait déjà bien 20 ans
que je pêche sur la glace
et je ne suis jamais tombé à l'eau.
Vous voyez comme il est petit celui-là.
Il lui retire son hameçon
pour qu'il grandisse encore un peu.
Aujourd'hui, Youri
a un emploi du temps chargé.
Lui et ses hommes doivent
creuser un bassin dans la glace
pour le futur rassemblement
des nageurs en eau froide.
Vous êtes au courant des dimensions ?
Vous savez
à quelle distance, il faut creuser ?
C'est quoi la profondeur ?
De 4 mètres à 1,50 mètre.
En plein mois de janvier, la surface
du fleuve est aussi dur que l'acier.
Peu à peu,
les sauveteurs dessinent une croix.
Dans quelques jours, des milliers
de croyants viendront s'y baigner
pour célébrer le baptême du Christ,
une tradition risquée
que Youri doit sécuriser.
Couvre-toi vite !
Ne reste pas comme ça ! Tiens, prend ça !
Précautions indispensables,
Youri demande à ses hommes
d'explorer le fond de la Neva.
Il plonge pour vérifier le fond de l'eau,
s'il n'y a rien qui pourrait empêcher
l'installation de la structure en bois.
Qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait trouver ?
On peut trouver des déchets,
des carcasses de métal ou même un noyé.
Allô, tu vois le fond ?
Il y a quelque chose ?
Rien à signaler.
Maintenant, on dégage les lieux.
Il ne reste plus rien.
Tout est enfin prêt pour la touche finale.
Comme descendu des cieux,
une chapelle est posée au fond du fleuve.
De retour à leur base,
les sauveteurs-plongeurs s'accordent
une pause avant leur prochaine mission.
Après des heures passées dans le froid,
ils se sont préparés du sandre grillé.
Il vient du golfe de Finlande.
Il faut tout manger, même la tête.
Il ne faut pas jeter. C'est trop bon !
Les sauveteurs-plongeurs seront
de garde toute la nuit.
À ces latitudes septentrionales,
en hiver, la nuit tombe dès 16h.
Il est 10h, le jour se lève enfin.
Tu as bien dormi ?
On a fini tard hier.
Ta femme n'a rien dit ?
Dis-lui que c'est au nom de l'art.
Depuis deux semaines,
Marc, l'artiste français,
travaille 18 heures par jour
pour finir à temps ses tableaux en glace.
Tous les matins,
il retrouve ses assistants
dans l'arrière-cour de son immeuble,
transformé en atelier pour l'occasion.
Bonjour.
-Bien dormi ?
-Oui.
Aujourd'hui, je vais faire le toit.
Après, il faut préparer
les couleurs pour verser pour la maison.
Tu veux cette couleur ?
Oui, du jaune et du vert.
On peut faire ces fenêtres aussi.
Ensemble, ils préparent
la future exposition de Marc.
Je crois que j'aurais pu être orfèvre.
Mon voisin m'a dit : "Pourquoi
vous ne travaillez pas à l'intérieur ?"
J'ai dit : "C'est de la glace monsieur."
Il n'arrivait pas à le croire.
Il a pris : "Oui, c'est de la glace."
Marc doit terminer un tableau
de Monet très compliqué à copier.
Un à un, chaque trait de pinceau,
est remplacé
par des morceaux de glace teintée.
Déjà gelée.
On met dans l'eau chaude,
parce que la seringue est gelée.
Le bout, ça ne passe plus.
De l'eau, ni trop chaude,
ni trop froide en guise de colle,
tout est question de température.
Je crois qu'aujourd'hui,
il fait moins 10, moins 9, moins 10.
C'est une température parfaite.
Moins 8, c'est trop chaud.
La chaleur de ma main va
vite faire fondre la glace,
et moins 20,
c'est trop froid pour mes pieds.
Par contre, la glace est
parfaite, elle n'est pas mal.
Moi, j'aime bien les conditions extrêmes.
Marc a prévu
de présenter cinq tableaux au public
le jour du vernissage de son exposition.
Le travail presque terminé,
ne reste plus
qu'à tracer les lignes noires
sur l'hiver de Kandinsky et à prier.
Si la température réchauffe,
on sera obligé de leur dire au revoir.
Ils partiront dans la rivière.
En attendant l'exposition de Marc,
en cette journée du 18 janvier,
au pied de la forteresse Pierre-et-Paul,
on célèbre l'épiphanie.
Depuis la chute de l'URSS,
on assiste en Russie à la renaissance
de la foi orthodoxe et de ses rites.
Parmi les milliers de fidèles
venus aujourd'hui se baigner
dans l'eau bénite du fleuve, Nastya.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un jour particulier.
On fête tous ensemble l'épiphanie.
Je suis vraiment contente,
heureuse de m'être baignée
ici aujourd'hui,
puis, c'est tellement beau.
Le sang russe trouve
sa chaleur dans le froid,
comme l'a dit un célèbre écrivain.
Mais le froid n'est pas sans risque.
En-cas d'hydrocution,
la protection de Dieu ne suffit pas.
Les sauveteurs-plongeurs veillent.
Je vous aide ?
Non, merci. Peut-être quand je remonterai.
Exceptionnellement, Youri a délaissé
son uniforme réglementaire de sauveteur.
Attention, les gars,
voilà notre directeur.
Attention !
Seigneur !
Je me sens rechargé à fond.
Je suis plein d'énergie,
prêt à travailler beaucoup et longtemps,
à retourner le monde avec l'aide de Dieu.
Après le choc thermique,
tous les moyens sont bons
pour se réchauffer.
Cette année,
30 000 croyants auront affronté
les eaux glacées de la Neva.
Une semaine plus tard,
un réchauffement inhabituel a transformé
la ville en véritable pataugeoire.
Marc est inquiet pour ses tableaux.
La neige n'a pas fondu.
La température,
cette nuit, est montée à un degré,
deux degrés
maintenant et il pleut en plus.
Il a fallu faire
un sarcophage pour les œuvres d'art,
pour pas qu'elles fondent.
Ça, c'est l'œuvre maîtresse et Matisse.
Il faut se dépêcher
parce qu'il pleut maintenant.
Le vernissage de Marc est compromis.
Les heures sont comptées.
Tu n'as pas prévu un gyrophare ?
Marc a prévu de faire
son exposition éphémère
au pied des colonnes rostrale,
en face de l'Ermitage,
sur les bords de la Neva.
C'est lourd. On pose.
Sans autorisation,
l'artiste doit faire vite
pour ne pas être repéré par la police.
On peut le faire glisser.
Pour plus de discrétion,
l'exposition sauvage ne commencera
qu'à la nuit tombée.
Il faut tout retirer, le plexiglas aussi.
Retirez tout.
Je vais regarder une minute.
Il a changé un peu, mais il n'a pas fondu.
Chevalet, cadre et éclairage,
les copies des tableaux de l'Ermitage
vont être dévoilées en grande pompe.
Sois prêt. Qui a un briquet ?
Bravo [inaudible 00:49:39-00:49:40]
La ronde de Marc est
fidèle à l'original de Matisse.
Et l'hiver de Kandinsky !
S'ensuivre la meule de foin de Monet.
Le clou du spectacle,
un Picasso en relief.
Du vin pour Picasso.
Merci Alicia, Alexeï,
merci de m'avoir supporté.
Ce sont des gens si calmes,
contrairement à moi qui suis volcanique.
Pour couronner son succès,
Marc peut compter
sur un feu d'artifice inattendu.
Sans le savoir,
l'artiste français a organisé
son exposition le soir de la célébration
de la fin du siège de Leningrad en 1945.
Saint-Pétersbourg,
la ville où tout est possible,
brille à nouveau de tous ses feux.